[Música]
[Aplausos]
eu fui levar meu pai na emergência
ele estava com pressão alta logo que
chegamos ele foi encaminhado enfermaria
e eu fiquei com a sua carteira e seu
celular
tinha que preencher o prontuário médico
faça
peguei a caneta no dia tampa biotipo
sanguíneo não sabia alergia medicação
não sabia teve sarampo caxumba catapora
não sabia e medicação estava tomando
não sabia aquela folha de entrada no
hospital é da minha reprovação como
filho
eu não sabia nada do meu pai
ele sabe decorre meu pai um estranho
íntimo
eu nunca perdi tempo para fazer
perguntas banais e relevantes
essa banalidade da urgência o nome
esforcei para amar o meu pai assim como
esforço para chamar os amigos
ele chegou com uma encomenda pronta
eu nunca quis saber se ele tinha um
cachorro na infância
qual o nome do seu cachorro
quem foi o seu primeiro amor
se ele ficava de castigo
quais foram as suas notas
ele nadava pedalava eu desconhecia o meu
pai porque eu vinha a paternidade ea
maternidade como uma via de mão única em
que eu só tinha que receber os pais eram
funções
o pai a mãe funções
eu não percebi que havia pessoas morando
nessas funções
pessoas com vacilações hesitações
desejas pessoas que mudam de opinião que
não enxergava os meus pais eu me
enxergava através deles e só pedir e só
queria e só esse dia
mesmo aquele que não teve um bom pai uma
boa mãe carrega a certeza de que foi
enganado e não pensa que o pai ea mãe
não tinham mais o que oferecer
deram tudo o que tinham
se não deram mais aqui no dia só que
carregamos essa idealização do pai e da
mãe ea gente cobra
imagine que está do outro lado sendo
cobrado e não tem mais o que dá é que
não está escondendo o jogo não tem mais
o que oferecer
mesmo sendo a pior versão é a melhor
versão é ainda melhor versão deles é
torturar eu não reparava os sinais a
minha mãe e meu pai pede ajuda eu não
reparava sempre que eu vou visitar minha
mãe ela acha que eu sou morto de fome
eu estou lá conversando conversando
conversa noide sair expedir e baixar a
cabeça para a bênção e o baixo a cabeça
cada vez mais porque minha mãe vai
decidir no hindu de corpo e crescendo e
alma
ela vem só com um minuto e eu escuto o
chinelo dela arrastado até a geladeira e
ela me vem com uma sacola de comida
eu não quero não tô com fome
eu já comi leva é um pudim e é um feijão
e é pedaço de lasanha porque a mãe
mesmo não estando os quatro filhos
continua cozinhando como os quatros
filhos estivessem ali
aí ela diz aquilo que ela queria dizer
não esqueça
devolver os portes eo raciocinava que
manhã 40 me dar comida e cobra o pote e
não identificava que ela comprava potes
com o pretexto de dizer isso ela não
estava preocupada com a devolução dos
esportes
ela só queria que eu voltasse
ela me ligava os potes para garantir a
próxima visita a minha mãe não era pra
estar daqui quando tinha sete anos
fui aprender a ler ea escrever e fui
convidado a sair da escola
antes eu fui encaminhado a um neuro que
diagnosticou que eu tinha retardo mental
a minha mãe foi até a escola sem que eu
soubesse de nada e falou para a
professora me dá dois meses dois meses
eu ensino fabrício a ler e escrever
todos os remédios que eu recebi ela
jogou na pia e foi me ensinando a ler e
escrever
a partir de jogos quebra-cabeça bambolê
detetive
eu nem sabia que eu estava aprendendo eu
pensei que eu tinha exclusividade da
minha mãe
as férias da minha mãe ela pediu licença
no trabalho pra ensinar dois meses parou
o seu tempo por mim em dois meses
eu voltei para a escola
escrevendo e lendo melhor que os meus
colegas diagnóstico não é destino você
pode receber o diagnóstico de seis meses
de vida e viver 16 anos
o diagnóstico é o retrato provisório não
é definitivo não inclui garra
persistência e vontade amor cuidado fé
eu sou filho da
é da minha mãe
você pode aprender qualquer coisa na
vida sozinho lealdade fidelidade - fé fé
a gente precisa receber de alguém
a fé é sempre emprestada a minha mãe
vive com uma pergunta fúnebre
quando eu morrer o que você deseja de
herança não vai morrer aquela mentira
educada para de falar isso para de
bobagem e ela existiu incomodou me
perturbou até que eu tive que falar não
quero a casa da mãe carro da mãe
biblioteca da mãe quadros móveis não o
que eu quero da minha mãe é é a casa
cheia de botões
ela se uma caixinha mágica de botões
sempre que eu perdi um botão
não importa aonde tinha cópia exata
naquela caixinha era um circo de botões
um circo mágico de motores
podia ser um botão amarelo e lá estava o
mesmo botão amarelo na caixinha
prontamente e passa a camisa que eu vou
costurar eu fazia menção de tirar ela
não fique aí e trazia um banquinho de
madeira e humildemente se agachava antes
20 a teus olhos são melhores que os meus
pode colocar a linha na cabeça da agulha
eu colocava e ela costurava aquele botão
do meu corpo e eu querendo sair e eu
querendo brincar e ela vai se machucar
aguenta
eu só sei abraçar hoje por esse tempo
que eu ficava diante da minha mãe
essa trégua
esse intervalo da ternura e que ela me
olhava nos olhos
e vocês acham que ela somente costurou
um botão mimi o quanto que ela fechou
meu corpo
o quanto que ela fechou meu corpo com
esperança
esses dias o jantar com a mãe ela fez um
gesto brusco e vi rodopiar um botão da
manga de sua camisa
eu disse ficar quieta e fui lá com
agulha ele
fiquei na frente dela e eu que costumo
importa-me costurando os botões dos seus
olhos brilhavam excelência e eu devolvi
um botão de centenas de botões um só
botão
mas qual é difícil devolver esse
primeiro botão como é difícil a gente
perdoa com mais facilidade que nos faz
mal do que quem nos faz bem porque a
gente não sabe como pagar a dívida da
gratidão
a gente não sabe como recompensar
eu me emociono quando vejo um box do
banheiro uma barra porque eu sei que
aquela casa é de um filho que cuidou do
seu pai e velho da sua mãe dele e
aproveitou a generosidade da vida porque
aquele pai aquela mãe que nos ensinaram
a andar falar a ficar de pé
a gente pode depois na velhice
ensiná-los a voltada ao voltar a falar a
voltar a lembrar a gente pode devolver o
que recebemos
além das funções
do filho que se despede somente no
enterro
contudo e tal lado na garganta
tendo que perguntar e responder por
alguém que não está mais sendo que
imaginara em atender e feliz do filho
que se despede um pouco por dia que
aceita imperfeição que aceita o possível
que aceita os encontros quebrados que
aceita falha que aceita o amor botão a
bottle linha costurado por que não temos
medo da morte
a gente não tem medo da morte
a gente tem medo da solidão
a gente tem medo de morrer sozinho o que
o pai o que a mãe querem ouvir no fim de
sua vida não é o eu te amo
por mais que eu te amo esteja escondido
hipóteses o que eles querem ouvir
é apenas isso pai eu estou aqui
mãe eu estou aqui
ele só não quer
martin sozinhos
estou aqui estou aqui estou aqui estou
aqui estou
[Aplausos]